gabriela y lourdes se dieron cuenta de
que podían expresar su edad de una forma
más específica si usaban fracciones usar
fracciones les permitirá calcular la
diferencia entre sus edades de una forma
más precisa si gabriela describe su edad
como quince años y medio
quince y un medio de años y lourdes
describe la suya como siete años y siete
doceavos cuántos años hay de diferencia
o sea cuántos años se llevan gabi y
lourdes escribe la respuesta como un
número mixto simplificado ok entonces lo
que nos están pidiendo es que digamos
cuántos años se llevan gabi y lourdes y
javi tiene quince años y medio
y lourdes tiene 7 años y 7 12 años de
año entonces gabi es más grande que
lourdes y para ver cuántos años se
llevan lo que tenemos que hacer es
restar las dos edades y como son números
mixtos aquí ya sabemos que esto es 15
más un medio menos y entre paréntesis 77
doceavos que termina siendo menos 7 y
menos 7 doceavos pero si nos fijamos
aquí este un medio si lo convertimos a
una fracción que tiene como denominador
12 en realidad lo que tenemos es 6 12
bosh y 6 12 a 2 es más chico que 7
doceavos entonces a la hora de hacer la
resta aquí nos va a quedar un entero y
luego una fracción negativa entonces en
lugar de estar haciendo todo ese relajo
de que los enteros presten 1 para que se
reste con esa fracción que tiene el
signo negativo lo que vamos a hacer es
convertir estos dos números a fracciones
impropias y así ya no tenemos que hacer
todo ese cambalache de que nos presten y
toda la onda
ok entonces hagamos eso vamos a
convertirlo a fracciones impropias
entonces 15 y un medio a la hora de
convertir la fracción impropia lo que
tenemos que hacer
aquí nos va a quedar en medio y aquí
tenemos un 1 y ese 1 le tenemos que
sumar 15 por 2 15 por 2 son 30
más el 1 que ya teníamos sí porque 15 en
realidad son 30 medios y por otro lado
ahora vamos a convertir esta fracción en
una fracción impropia nuestro
denominador van a ser 12 a 2 y aquí este
7 lo vamos a escribir como 7 por 12
entre 12 y cuánto es 7 por 12 7 por 2 14
llevamos 17 por 17 y 18 o sea 7 por 12
es 84 y le tenemos que sumar los 7 que
ya teníamos 0 84 7 cuánto es 91 entonces
vamos a escribir aquí 91 y 30 más uno
pues es 31 no
31 y los tenemos que restar ahora para
restar estas dos fracciones impropias
tenemos que hacer que tengan el mismo
denominador y para eso hay que encontrar
el mínimo común múltiplo de estas dos
cosas pero eso es muy fácil porque el 2
divide al 12 y el 12 divide al 12
entonces cómo estos dos números dividen
al 12 el 12 es un múltiplo común de los
dos y además es el más chico que puede
haber porque aquí tenemos un 12 entonces
nuestro denominador común va a ser el 12
y por acá 12 y se están restando a ver
para pasar de esta fracción a esta
fracción como no le hicimos nada al
denominador no le tenemos que hacer nada
el numerador y pasa simplemente en 91 y
para pasar de esta fracción a esta
fracción por cuánto necesito multiplicar
el 2 para que me dé 12 por 6 no 2 por 6
son 12 y entonces tengo que multiplicar
el numerador por 6 que tenemos que pasar
de aquí para acá multiplicando por 6
si es que 31 por 6 cuánto es haber 6 por
1 son 6 6 por 3 18
y listo
y bueno la resta de estas dos fracciones
tiene el mismo denominador 12
y en el numerador tenemos 186 menos 91
al 6 le vamos a restar 1 y nos queda 5 y
después a 180 le vamos a restar 90 y nos
va a quedar 90
entonces en total nos va a quedar 95
entonces gabi tiene 95 12 años de años
más que lourdes ok este es el resultado
de 15 años y medio menos 77 doceavos de
años pero nos están pidiendo que
escribamos la respuesta como un número
mixto simplificado ok entonces tenemos
que ver cuántos entre los hay aquí así
es que tenemos que dividir 95
entre 12 y bueno 12 por 8 es 96 así es
que ahí ya nos pasamos pero está muy
cerca entonces yo creo que va a ser el 7
a ver veamos 7 por 2 14 4 y llevamos 17
por 17 y 18 8 y tenemos que restar esto
y lo que nos queda son 5 menos 4 19
menos 81 entonces 95 12 ambos son 7
enteros y nos queda de residuo
11 así es que aquí va un 11 12 a vos
ok gabriela le lleva 7 años y 11 12 años
de año a lourdes